kosovo's prime minister is holding talks
with EU and U.S representatives after
days of unrest violence broke out after
the election of ethnic Albanian Mayors
in Serb majority areas and a Turkish
Commando Battalion has arrived in Kosovo
this at the request of NATO dozens of
the alliance's soldiers were injured in
confrontations last week the EU has
threatened to impose sanctions on both
Serbia and Kosovo if the violence
continues
meanwhile Italian peacekeepers are
guarding the city of leposavich in
Northern Kosovo barbed wire was raised
around the municipal buildings where
ethnic Albanian Mayors are supposed to
take office
the majority served population boycotted
local elections in April it comes after
Mass protests spiraled into violence in
the city
acid big is in Pristina can talk to us
about all of this I said let's start
with who's talking and what they're
aiming to achieve
well we have the special envoys from the
EU and the United States we have
Miroslav lychic from the EU and we have
Gabriel Escobar from the United States
now they will be speaking we understand
to the Kosovo prime minister Alvin kurti
now we expect some tough talking both
the United States and the EU have come
out very publicly condemned and
criticized Kosovo for the actions in the
north of Kosovo they say it was the
government here that decided to send in
the special police units to ensure that
those ethnic Albanian Mayors took off
this in those local government buildings
that started this violence but when you
speak to politicians here anyone who
speak to ethnic albanians they're
slightly perplexed by the EU and the U.S
response these are supposed to be
kosovo's allies these are supposed to be
kosovo's friends and they're really
concerned about why it is that they are
criticizing Kosovo so much because it
was an ethnic albanians they say that
attacked NATO soldiers it wasn't ethnic
albanians that were involved in the
violence now we understand that 15 of
those soldiers Italian soldiers have
returned to Italy today but there will
be some tough talking about Alvin kurti
the Prime Minister here isn't a
difficult position he has considerable
support within Kosovo and he has
suggested that there could be a fresh
round of Elections but if though the
ethnics decide to break up the election
again he will find himself in the very
same position but also for him this is a
question of sovereignty it's about
Kosovo sovereignty and the north of
Kosovo especially those four
municipalities that are majority ethnic
Serb he sees as an extension of Serbia
they the government here has openly
blamed Belgrade for interfering inside
costs for for instigating and
orchestrating these protests and
violence so he's in a very difficult
position there's a lot of pressure from
the EU and U.S threatening sanctions as
you said but at the same time he can't
compromise within Kosovo because says he
has based his reputation on the
sovereignty of Kosovo on the rule of law
and he says that he has a right and a
duty to uphold the Constitution
I said we saw from your last report no
later than today that things in North
Kosovo right now in Vietnam specifically
are relatively quiet right now but
you're reporting throughout the week has
also shown that there's always a risk of
a flare-up in that region
absolutely there hasn't been any more
violence towards NATO soldiers but we
have constant reports from Kosovo police
that their vehicles and and police
officers have been targeted in those
municipalities and just earlier in the
week two ethnic albanians were targeted
by what the government here said were a
fascist militia in North Metro so that's
always an issue and the challenge that
the government here faces is that those
ethnic serbs in the north they consider
the north not only the north but all of
Kosovo are support of Serbia when you go
there they are Serbian Flags the
userbian currency and when you speak to
people they say this is Serbia this is
Serbia again and again and again it is
considerable tension and hostility as
well when Outsiders go go in journalists
have been targeted and and police as
I've said so the situation remains tense
but what's interesting is that these
special envoys have gone to Belgrade and
the now come to Christina we don't think
that we haven't heard that there will be
meeting ethnic serve leaders in the
north of Kosovo and many people believe
that's because there's an acknowledgment
that the reality is that it's Belgrade
and Pristina that make the decisions
that will affect what happens in the
north of Kosovo
acid Bay reporting from Christina thank
you very much